C'est génial d'être de retour.
J'adore ce public fantastique.
Et vous devez vous demander, "qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont mis le mauvais slide ?"
Non, non.
Regardez cette bête magnifique et demandez-vous -- qui l'a créée ?
On est à TED.
C'est à dire "Technology, Entertainment, Design" (ndlt : Technologie, Divertissement, Design) et voici une vache laitière.
Le design de cet animal est assez fantastique.
Et je me demandais, comment vais-je introduire cela ?
Et je pensais, bon, peut-être ce vieux vers boiteux de Joyce Kilmer,
vous savez : "Les poèmes sont fait par des idiots comme moi,
mais seul Dieu peut faire un arbre."
Et vous pourriez vous dire, "eh bien, Dieu a 'designé' cette vache."
Mais, bien sûr, Dieu a beaucoup été aidé.
Voici l'ancêtre des vaches.
C'est un Auroch.
Et il a été "designé" par la sélection naturelle,
le processus de la sélection naturelle, pendant plusieurs millions d'années.
et puis il a été domestiqué il y a des milliers d'années.
Et les êtres humains en sont devenus responsables.
et, sans même savoir ce qu'ils faisaient,
ils l'ont progressivement "redesigné," "redesigné" et "redesigné."
et puis, plus récemment, ils ont réellement commencé
la rétro-ingénierie de cet animal
pour bien en comprendre les différents éléments, leur fonctionnement
et comment on pourrait bien les optimiser -- comment on pourrait les améliorer.
Et pourquoi suis-je en train de parler de vaches ?
Parce que je veux dire que ceci, en grande partie, est aussi vrai des religions.
Les religions sont des phénomènes naturels.
Elles sont justes aussi naturelles que les vaches.
Elles ont évolué pendant des millénaires.
Elles ont une base biologique, tout comme l'Auroch.
Elles ont été domestiquées, et les êtres humains
on constamment "redesigné" leurs religions pendant des milliers d'années.
On est à TED, et je voudrais parler de design.
Parce que ce que j'ai fait au cours des quatre dernières années,
depuis que vous m'avez vu pour la première fois -- certains d'entre vous m'ont vu à TED
quand je parlais de religion, et au cours des quatre dernières années
j'ai travaillé sans relâche sur ce sujet.
et vous pourriez vous dire qu'il s'agit de la rétro-ingénierie des religions
maintenant je pense que cette idée sème la terreur chez beaucoup de gens,
ou, d'une façon ou d'une autre, la colère et l'anxiété.
et c'est le "sortilège" que je veux briser.
Je veux dire, non, les religions sont un important phénomène naturel.
Nous devrions les étudier avec la même énergie
avec laquelle nous étudions les autres phénomènes naturels importants,
tels que le réchauffement climatique, comme nous l'avons si éloquemment entendu d'Al Gore hier soir.
Les religions d'aujourd'hui sont brillamment "designées" -- brillamment "designées".
Ce sont des institutions sociales au pouvoir immense
et beaucoup de leurs caractéristiques remontent à des caractéristiques primitives
dont nous pouvons comprendre grâce à la rétro-ingénierie.
Et, comme dans le cas de la vache, c'est un mélange d'évolution,
de sélection naturelle et de "dessein intelligent" --
plus ou moins du "dessein intelligent" -- repris par les êtres humains
qui essayent de "redesigner" leurs religions.
On ne cause pas de livres à TED, mais je vais vous passer juste un slide
sur mon livre, car il y a un message dedans
que ce groupe, je pense, à réellement besoin d'entendre.
Et j'aimerais bien connaître vos réactions.
C'est la politique que je propose dans ce livre,
à un moment où je dis que je n'en sais pas assez sur la religion
pour savoir quelles autres politiques proposer.
Et c'en est une qui fait écho à des remarques que vous avez déjà entendues aujourd'hui.
Voici ma proposition.
Je vais juste prendre deux minutes pour l'expliquer --
éduquer tout nos enfants sur les religions du monde,
dans les lycées, les écoles publiques, les écoles privées et les cours à la maison.
Donc ce que je propose, c'est
tout comme nous exigeons de savoir lire, écrire et compter et de connaître l'histoire,
nous devrions avoir une formation sur les faits
concernant toutes les religions du monde --
concernant leurs histoires, leurs credos, leurs textes,
leurs musiques, leurs symbolismes, leurs interdits, leurs exigences,
et ceci devrait être présenté factuellement, sans détour,
sans biais particulier, à tous les enfants du pays.
Et du moment que vous leur enseignez cela,
vous pouvez leur enseigner tout ce qui vous plaît.
Ceci, je pense, respecte au maximum la liberté de culte.
Tant que vous informez vos enfants sur les autres religions
vous pouvez --- aussi tôt que vous le souhaitez et quelles que soient vos inclinations,
leur apprendre n'importe quel credo que vous voulez qu'ils apprennent.
Mais laissez-les aussi connaître les autres religions.
Bon, pourquoi dis-je cela ?
Parce que la démocratie repose sur des citoyens informés
le consentement éclairé est la pierre angulaire
de la démocratie telle que nous la comprenons.
Un consentement non éclairé ne vaut rien.
c'est comme tirer à pile ou face pour décider -- ça ne compte pas en fait.
La démocratie repose sur un consentement éclairé.
C'est la façon dont nous traitons les gens en adultes responsables.
Maintenant, les enfants avant l'âge du libre consentement sont un cas particulier.
Je vais utiliser un mot que le Pasteur Rick a juste utilisé --
les parents sont les responsables des enfants.
Ils n'en sont pas les propriétaires.
Vous ne pouvez pas être propriétaires de vos enfants.
Vous êtes responsables devant le monde,
devant l'état, devant eux, de bien prendre soin d'eux.
Vous pouvez leur apprendre n'importe quel credo qui vous semble important,
mais je dis que vous avez la responsabilité de les informer aussi
à propos de tous les autres credos dans le monde.
J'ai pris le temps d'en parler car j'ai été fasciné d'entendre
certaines réactions à ma proposition.
Un critique d'un journal Catholique l'a qualifiée de "totalitaire".
Elle me frappe plutôt comme quasiment libertaire.
Est-ce totalitaire de demander de savoir lire, écrire et compter ?
Je ne pense pas.
Tout ce que je demande c'est -- des faits. Seulement des faits.
Pas de valeurs, juste des faits sur toutes les religions du monde.
Un autre critique l'a qualifiée de "hilarante".
Eh bien, je suis vraiment gêné par le fait que
qui que ce soit puisse penser qu'elle était hilarante.
Elle me semble à moi une extension
si plausible et si naturelle des principes démocratiques que nous avons déjà,
que je suis choqué de penser que quiconque puisse juste la trouver ridicule.
Je sais que beaucoup de religions sont très anxieuses de préserver la pureté
de leur foi chez leurs enfants qu'elles tentent
de maintenir leurs enfants ignorants des autres fois.
Je ne pense pas que cela est défendable, mais cela me ferait très plaisir
d'avoir vos réponses sur ça -- vos réactions à ça -- plus tard.
Mais maintenant je passe à la suite.
On revient à la vache.
Cette image, que j'ai tirée du web --
le gars sur la gauche est vraiment une partie importante de cette image.
C'est le "responsable".
Les vaches ne pourraient pas vivre sans humains qui répondent d'elles -- elles sont domestiquées
elles sont une sorte d'ectosymbionte.
Elles dépendent de nous pour leur survie.
Et le Pasteur Rick vient juste de parler de brebis.
Je vais parler de brebis aussi.
Il y a beaucoup d'heureuses coïncidences ici.
Comme les brebis ont été intelligentes de prendre des bergers !
Pensez à ce que cela leur a apporté.
Elles ont pu externaliser tous leurs problèmes --
se protéger des prédateurs, trouver de la nourriture, gérer leur santé.
Le seul coût pour la plupart des troupeaux est la perte des accouplements libres.
Quel coup de maître !
"Comme les brebis sont intelligentes!" pourriez-vous dire.
Sauf que, bien sûr, ce n'était pas grâce à l'intelligence des brebis.
Nous savons tous que les brebis ne sont pas exactement des astrophysiciennes -- elles ne sont pas très futées.
Ce n'était pas du tout l'intelligence des brebis.
Elles n'en avaient pas la moindre idée.
Mais c'était un coup très intelligent.
Un coup de qui ?
C'était un coup intelligent de la sélection naturelle elle-même.
Francis Crick, le co-découvreur de la structure de l'ADN
avec Jim Watson, avait une fois plaisanté à propos de ce qu'il appelait la deuxième règle d'Orgel.
Leslie Orgel est toujours un biologiste moléculaire, un type brillant,
et la deuxième règle d'Orgel est : l'Evolution est plus intelligente que vous.
Eh bien, ce n'est pas du "Dessein Intelligent" -- pas de Francis Crick.
L'Evolution est plus intelligente que vous.
Si vous comprenez la deuxième règle d'Orgel, alors vous comprenez
pourquoi le mouvement du "Dessein Intelligent" est un canular de base.
Les desseins révélés par le processus de la sélection naturelle
sont brillants, incroyablement brillants.
Encore et toujours, les biologistes sont fascinés par le côté brillant de ce qui est découvert.
Mais le processus lui-même n'a pas de finalité.
Il n'y a ni vision ni conception.
Quand j'étais ici il y a quatre ans,
J'ai raconté l'histoire de la fourmi qui monte sur un brin d'herbe.
Et pourquoi cette fourmi le fait-elle ?
Eh bien, c'est parce que sont cerveau a été infecté par un trématode (ndlt : la petite douve du foie) --
qui avait besoin d'arriver dans le ventre d'un mouton ou d'une vache pour se reproduire.
C'était une histoire qui fait peur.
Et je pense que certaines personne ont peut-être mal compris.
Les douves du foie ne sont pas intelligentes.
Je soutient que l'intelligence de la douve du foie se situe au ras
des pâquerettes, entre le pétunia et la carotte.
Elles ne sont pas vraiment des lumières. Elles n'en ont pas besoin.
La leçon pour nous, c'est que
vous n'avez pas besoin d'être doué d'un esprit pour tirer parti de quelque chose.
Le dessein est dans la nature, et pas dans la tête de quelqu'un.
Il n'a pas besoin de l'être.
C'est de cette façon que l'évolution travaille.
La question -- est-ce que la domestication a été bonne pour les moutons ?
Elle a été super pour leur adéquation génétique.
Et maintenant je voudrais vous rappeler un point fantastique
que Paul MacCready a fait à TED il y a trois ans.
Voici ce qu'il a dit.
Il y a 10.000 ans, à l'aube de l'agriculture,
la population humaine, plus le bétail et les animaux de compagnie, représentaient approximativement
un dixième de pourcent de la masse des vertébrés terrestres.
C'était il y a juste 10.000 ans.
Hier en termes biologiques.
Que représente-t-elle aujourd'hui ? Est-ce que quelqu'un se rappelle de ce qu'il nous a dit ?
98 pour cent.
C'est ce que nous avons fait sur cette planète.
Eh bien j'ai parlé à Paul après.
Je voulais vérifier comment il avait calculé cela.
et obtenir les sources et tout.
Et il m'a donné une publication qu'il avait faite sur le sujet.
Elle contenait un passage qu'il n'a pas présenté ici
et je pense qu'il est si bon que je vais vous le lire.
"Au cours de milliards d'années sur une sphère unique,
le hasard a peint une fine couche de vie :
complexe, improbable, merveilleuse et fragile,
Soudainement, nous les humains, une espèce arrivée récemment
n'étant plus asujettis à toutes les contraintes inhérentes à la nature,
avons cru en population, technologie et intelligence et obtenu un pouvoir terrible.
C'est maintenant nous qui tenons le pinceau."
Nous savons que l'atmosphère est comme une fine couche de vernis.
La vie elle-même est juste une fiche couche de peinture sur cette planète.
Et nous sommes ceux qui tenons le pinceau.
Et comment pouvons nous le faire ?
La clef de notre domination sur la planète est la culture.
et la clef de la culture, c'est la religion.
Supposez que des scientifiques martiens viennent sur Terre.
Beaucoup de choses les rendraient perplexes.
Quelqu'un sait ce que c'est ?
Je vais vous le dire.
C'est un rassemblement d'un million de gens sur les rives du Gange en 2001,
peut-être le plus grand rassemblement humain de tous les temps,
photographié par satellite.
Voici une grande foule.
Voici une autre foule à la Mecque.
Les martiens seraient émerveillés par ça.
Ils voudraient en connaître l'origine, le but et comment cela se perpétue.
En fait, je vais passer à autre chose.
La fourmi n'est pas seule.
Il y a toute sorte de cas d'espèces extraordinaires.
Dans ce cas, un parasite infecte une souris
et il a besoin d'arriver dans le ventre d'un chat.
Et il transforme la souris en Super Souris -- elle n'a plus peur de rien,
donc elle court sans défense a découvert, et le chat la mange.
Histoire vraie.
En d'autres termes, nous avons ces preneurs d'otages --
vous avez vu ce slide avant, il y a quatre ans --
un parasite qui infecte le cerveau
et même induit un comportement suicidaire pour une cause
extérieure aux buts génétiques de l'hôte.
Est-ce que cela peut nous arriver ?
Oui, cela arrive -- assez merveilleusement.
Le mot Arabe "Islam" signifie soumission.
Il signifie soumission des intérêts égoïstes à la volonté d'Allah.
Mais je ne parle pas que de l'Islam.
Je parle aussi de la chrétienté.
Ceci est une page de musique en parchemin que j'ai trouvé chez un bouquiniste à Paris il y a 50 ans.
Et on peut lire dessus en Latin :
(Latin)
"La parole divine est une graine et le semeur de la graine est le Christ."
La même idée! A peu de choses près.
Mais en fait, les chrétiens aussi glorifient le fait de se soumettre au seigneur.
Je vais vous lire quelques citations.
"Le cœur de l'adoration est la soumission.
Les gens soumis obéissent à la parole divine, même s'ils ne la comprennent pas."
Ce sont les mots de Rick Warren.
Ils proviennent de "La vie motivée par l'essentiel".
Et je voudrais maintenant, brièvement, parler de ce livre, que j'ai lu.
Vous avez tous un exemplaire.
Vous venez juste d'écouter ce monsieur.
Et ce que je voudrais faire maintenant est parler un peu de ce livre du point de vue de sa conception,
parce qu'en fait, je pense vraiment que c'est un livre brillant.
En premier lieu son but.
Et vous venez juste d'entendre en quoi consiste son but.
Il s'agit de donner un but dans la vie à des millions de gens, et il a réussi.
Est-ce un bon but ?
En soi, je suis sur que nous sommes tous d'accord, c'est un but merveilleux.
Il a absolument raison.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de but dans la vie,
et leur donner un but est un objectif magnifique.
Je lui donne un 18/20 pour ça.
A-t-il atteint son but ?
Oui.
Il en est à 30 millions d'exemplaires.
Al Gore, fais-toi hara-kiri.
(Rires)
Ce que Al essaye de faire, Rick le fait.
C'est une réussite fantastique.
Et avec quels moyens -- comment fait-il ?
C'est un "redesign" brillant des thèmes religieux traditionnels --
il les met à jour, en se débarrassant discrètement des caractéristiques obsolètes,
donnant de nouvelles interprétations sur d'autres caractéristiques.
C'est l'évolution des religions qui continue depuis des milliers d'années,
et il en est juste un des derniers et brillant praticien.
Je n'ai pas à vous le dire,
Vous venez juste d'entendre ce monsieur.
D'excellentes vues sur la psychologie humaine, des conseils sages à chaque page.
De plus, il nous invite à regarder sous le capot.
J'ai vraiment apprécié cela.
Par exemple, il y a un appendice où il explique
ses choix de traduction de différents versets bibliques.
Le livre est clair, vivant, accessible, avec un joli format.
Avec juste assez de répétitions.
ça c'est vraiment important.
Chaque fois que vous le lisez ou vous le dites, vous en faites une autre copie dans votre cerveau.
(rires)
avec moi, tous ensembles -- Chaque fois que vous le lisez ou vous le dites,
vous en faites une autre copie dans votre cerveau.
Merci.
Et maintenant, venons en à mon problème.
Parce que je suis absolument sincère dans mon appréciation
de tout ce que j'ai dit à propos de ce livre.
Mais je souhaiterais qu'il soit meilleur.
J'ai des problèmes avec ce livre.
Et ce serait juste un manque de sincérité de ma part de passer sous silence ces problèmes.
Je voudrais bien qu'il puisse le faire avec une édition révisée,
une version 2 de son livre.
"La vérité vous libèrera" --
c'est ce qui est dit dans la Bible, et c'est aussi un principe selon lequel je veux vivre.
Mon problème c'est que je pense que certains passages de ce livre sont faux.
Pour une part c'est une divergence d'opinion,
et ce n'est pas mon reproche principal.
Il faut juste le mentionner.
Voici un passage -- c'est en grande partie ce qu'il a dit, de toutes façons.
"S'il n'y avait pas de Dieu, nous serions tous des accidents,
le résultat d'un aléa astronomique dans l'Univers.
Vous pourriez arrêter de lire ce livre car la vie
n'aurait pas de finalité ou de signification.
Il n'y aurait ni bien ni mal, ni espoir au delà de vos brèves années sur la terre."
Eh bien, je ne crois pas du tout cela.
Au passage, je trouve que le film de Homer Groening
présentait une belle alternative à cette même affirmation.
Oui, il y a un sens et une raison pour le bien et le mal.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de croire en Dieu pour être bons et pour faire sens.
Mais c'est juste une différence d'opinion.
Ce n'est pas vraiment ce qui me préoccupe.
Que pensez-vous de cela ? -- "Dieu a conçu l'environnement de cette planète pour que nous puissions y vivre."
J'ai bien peur que beaucoup de gens pensent que cela signifie
que nous n'avons pas à faire le genre de choses qu'Al Gore
essaye avec autant d'énergie de nous faire faire.
Je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce genre d'idée.
et puis je tombe sur ça -- "toutes les preuves données par la science biologique
soutiennent la proposition fondamentale que le cosmos a été conçu comme un tout
avec la vie et le genre humain comme but et finalité fondamentaux,
un tout dans lequel toutes les facettes de la réalité ont leur signification
et leur explication dans ce fait central."
Bon, ça c'est de Michael Denton. C'est un créationniste.
Et là je pense, "attends une minute."
Je le relis.
Je le relis trois ou quatre fois et je pense,
"Est-ce qu'il soutient vraiment le "Dessein Intelligent" ?
Est-ce qu'il soutient le créationnisme là ?"
Et on ne peut pas savoir.
Donc je me mets à penser, "bon, je sais pas,
Je ne sais pas si je veux déjà m'énerver là-dessus."
Et puis je reprends ma lecture et je lis ça --"Tout d'abord, Noé n'avait jamais vu la pluie,
car avant le déluge Dieu irriguait la terre par en dessous."
Je voudrais bien que cette phrase n'y soit pas, car je pense qu'elle est fausse.
Et je pense que penser de cette façon l'histoire de la planète,
après que nous venions d'entendre l'histoire de la planète
sur des millions d'années,
éloigne les gens de la compréhension scientifique des choses.
Bon, Rick Warren utilise des termes scientifiques et des pseudo-faits
et informations d'une façon très intéressante.
En voici un -- "Dieu vous a délibérément donné forme pour le servir
d'une façon qui rend votre ministère unique.
Il a dosé avec soin le cocktail d'ADN qui vous a créé."
Je pense que c'est faux.
Bon nous pourrions le prendre comme une métaphore.
Voici un autre exemple -- "Par exemple, votre cerveau peut stocker 100 trillions de faits.
Votre esprit peut gérer 15.000 décisions par seconde."
Eh bien, ce serait intéressant de trouver une interprétation où j'accepterais ça.
Il se peut qu'il y ait une façon de traiter ceci comme vrai.
"Les anthropologues ont noté que le culte est un besoin universel,
installé par Dieu dans la fibre même de notre être,
un besoin inné de se connecter à Dieu."
Eh bien, en un sens je suis d'accord avec lui,
sauf que je pense qu'il y a une explication par l'évolution.
Et ce que je trouve profondément gênant dans ce livre
est qu'il semble soutenir que si vous voulez être moral,
si vous voulez donner un sens à votre vie,
vous devez adhérer au "Dessein Intelligent" -- vous devez renier
la théorie de l'évolution par la sélection naturelle.
Et je pense, au contraire que c'est très important pour résoudre
les problèmes de ce monde que nous prenions la biologie de l'évolution très au sérieux.
De qui allons nous écouter la vérité ?
Eh bien, ceci est tiré de "Motivé par l'essentiel" --
"La Bible doit faire autorité dans ma vie,
devenir la boussole à laquelle je me fie pour me diriger, le conseil que j'écoute
pour prendre les bonnes décisions et la mesure que j'utilise pour tout évaluer."
Bon, peut-être, OK, mais qu'est-ce qui va en découler ?
Et en voici une qui me préoccupe vraiment.
Rappelez-vous que je l'ai cité avant avec cette phrase --
"Les gens soumis obéissent à la parole divine, même s'ils ne la comprennent pas."
Et ça, c'est un problème.
"Ne débattez jamais avec le diable.
C'est un meilleur polémiste que vous, il a des milliers d'années de pratique."
Bon, Rick Warren n'a pas inventé cette astuce.
C'est une vieille astuce.
C'est une très astucieuse capacité à s'adapter des religions.
C'est un joker pour désarmer toute critique rationnelle.
"Vous n'aimez pas mon interprétation ?
Vous avez une objection rationnelle ?
N'écoutez pas, n'écoutez pas !
C'est le diable qui parle."
Cela décourage le genre de citoyenneté rationnelle
qu'il me semble, nous voulons.
J'ai un problème de plus et après, j'ai fini.
Et j'aimerais vraiment avoir une réponse, si Rick en est capable.
"Dans la 'Grande Commission' (ndlt : Matthieu XXVIII, 18:20, Jésus a dit, 'Allez donc et instruisez tous les peuples,
les baptisant au nom du Père, du Fils et du Saint-Esprit,
et leur apprenant à observer toutes les choses que je vous ai commandées."
La Bible dit que Jésus est le seul qui puisse sauver le monde.
Bien, ici nous avons vu beaucoup de cartes magnifiques du monde
dans les derniers jours.
En voici une, pas aussi jolie que les autres.
Elle montre simplement les religions du monde.
Et en voici une qui montre la répartition actuelle des différentes religions.
Voulons nous vraiment nous engager à absorber
toutes les autres religions quand leurs livres saints leur disent
"n'écoutez pas les autres, c'est Satan qui parle!"
Cela me semble un vaisseau très problématique
pour s'embarquer vers le futur.
J'ai trouvé ce panneau récemment, en conduisant pour aller dans le Maine,
devant une église -- "Sans Dieu le Bien est réduit à néant"
Plutôt mignon.
Un très astucieux petit mème.
Je n'en crois rien et je pense que cette idée, aussi populaire soit-elle -- pas sous cette forme
mais en général -- est en soi un des problèmes principaux que nous affrontons.
Si vous êtes comme moi, vous connaissez beaucoup d'excellents athées,
ou agnostiques, engagés, qui sont très bons sans l'aide d'un Dieu.
Et vous connaissez aussi beaucoup de personnes religieuses qui se cachent derrière leur sainteté
au lieu d'œuvrer pour le bien.
Donc, j'aimerais qu'on se débarrasse de ce mème.
Je souhaiterais que ce mème s'éteigne.
Merci beaucoup de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)